there is a kind of wander to the mystery
of it all what what's out there what
interesting things that we can't
possibly imagine you know there could be
all kinds of life forms bacteria all
this kind of stuff I tend to believe
that
um
you know it depends on the day I tend to
believe there's just a lot of very
primitive organisms just spread out
throughout and they build their little
things like bacteria type organisms
um
and just to think what kind of Worlds
there are because they're probably
really creative living organisms
because the conditions I guess the
question I'm
wondering to myself when I look out
there to the Stars how different are the
conditions on the different planets that
orbit those Stars
it will definitely be very different I
mean the variety out there is is huge
we know now that I think it's about
every other star has at least one planet
I I already mentioned the number of
stars in the galaxy I mean you know
that's it's a huge number of planets out
there so who knows what that looks like
all we know is that there's
there is a lot of variety we don't quite
yet understand
what drives that what governs that why
that is the case why is it not all one
size fits all or you mean the Dynamics
of Planet formation like exoplanet
formation or Star formation the whole
all of it all of it um star formation is
remains a much research topic
we kind of we definitely know that it
works because all the stars are there
same for the planets but the details are
so varied poor gas cloud right
um it's very hard to to come up with
very detailed prescriptions broadly we
have figured it out you need a gas cloud
you need to cool it
something clumps and fragments and
somehow it makes a star with planets or
without but the Dynamics of the clumping
process is not fully understood no no
and and the local conditions are so
varied right I mean it's the same with
you know all people look like people but
individually we look very different so
even the subtle diversity of the
formation process creates all kinds of
fun yes so you we just don't know how
this turned out in an individual case
and it's kind of hard to
to figure it all out and and to take a
look certainly with planets right the
chance forever to ever actually take a
picture of a planet is minuscule because
they don't shine so they're really dark
yeah so I'd say there's there's a lot of
possibility out there
but we have to be a little bit more
patient before we come up with
Technologies where patience becomes less
necessary by extending our lifetimes or
or increasing the speed of space travel
all the kind of stuff he was a pretty
pretty intelligent they're pretty uh
sometimes yeah for the most part I hope
and now when I'm on the optimistic days